we are starting with a story about a
hero in atlanta his name is keith walker
and cnn reports
he rushed into a burning animal shelter
and saved every
last animal i know
and keith is homeless himself he
went to the shelter to visit his dog
bravo
who stays there because they allow him
to do that and he saw smoke
ran in saved six cats and ten dogs you
brave hero and the w underdogs rescue
started a gofundme
to assist their hero keith their goal
was 5 000 and they've already raised
over
80 000. 80 000 yeah and he deserves it
and more so if you want to go and
support him as well
check out our website to do so good for
you keith
hey you know people are still going gaga
over the queen's gambit you know the
only reason i watch this show is because
drew barrymore told me to
thank you uh well and if you haven't
watched it you should and now pop sugar
reports
that not only can you watch the show you
can stay in the
harmon room at the museum hotel in
lexington kentucky
all inspired by the show and look at
that look how gorgeous these rooms are
it's fully decked out in retro decor and
the ceiling is a chess board yeah look
at that and you can
say for a queen or a king or a knight
okay next we've got a quick skincare
hack from someone that we all love here
the one and only chrissy teigen she
shared it i know i love her it hurts
anyway she shared on instagram if you
want to declog your
pores on the go put a pore strip
under your face mask it's so smart
because
hello it's covering your face anyway
there's nothing going on under there now
you can put one of these on
have you ever done a pore strip
literally maybe my favorite thing in the
world
okay how does it really work i've never
done it it is
so fun to put this on you sort of wet
your nose a little bit leave it on a
little bride of frankenstein
like 15 minutes later you pull it and
it's like really stuck on
and then you can it's so gross but i'm
gonna just talk about it okay
um oh my gosh i got one i'm not kidding
i see flex okay uh it's amazing to like
really go in on what you get
well i'm also like all about just you
know
in like skin care and improvement so
thank you teagan once again we will
heed your advice so smart